my name is Zoe Roth but you may know me
as disaster girl
this all started in 2005. I was five
years old and we were watching TV it was
a normal day me my brother Tristan and
my parents and we heard all these fire
sirens we go we walk outside and we see
like billowing smoke up just two blocks
away so we're like okay we're gonna go
check it out my dad had just gotten a
new camera we start walking down the
road and we see that there's this house
on fire at the time we thought it was a
real fire but all the Fire Marshals
weren't really in a rush to put it out
they were kind of just like walking
around they're letting like kids put out
the fire the house that was on fire was
donated to the fire department by the
owners for a test burn because they
wanted to clear the land like I didn't
know it was a test fire that nobody was
hurt so at the time I remember like
looking inside and trying to figure out
what was going on my dad was taking
pictures of the house and everything
going on and then he said it was my turn
to smile he was like okay smile so
that's why I made that face just because
that was my smile at the time